M
JUL
LLES VERY REAL
ON THED THE CONCERN ISO HAS BEE?
AFTER
SENATOR LINDGR TCOTOONA SENAF
THE
TH WAS IN SESSIOL
WEEKEND AND THERE WAS A THERINI
MAEBOAT HE LIVES OF
INASHINGTO
LINDSEY GRAHAM WAS THERE I'M
TOLD AND I TOLD ALSO A NUMBER OT
NDANCE.
YOU YODINGUMBER
SENATE REPUBLICA SENATOR MARKELT
ONG THLL OF OTHERSG
HAVING NICE TIMEND MOMEN
AGO, IED JOE AND ASKED HIM OUT
>> YOU GUYN'G
EVERYONE HAS BEE
NOW.LONG WAS THE EVENT?E FEELS O
WHATEVER TAKES
HAMBURGER OR TWO.
>> WAS IOORS?
>> ALL OUTDOORS.
VERAL OF T
HAVE EXPOSURETO LINDSEY GRAHAH
AR GIVENTIOUS
SEN                   SAIDMEASU
SHOULD GETD INCLUDING  OF SOUTHA
OPINION LOWLIC HEALTHFFICIALS
ID H
EXRIOMS RIGHT
NOW,
KATE?ACCINATEDOTHERWISE IT COULA
ABSOLUTELY.THANK YOU.OW IS DR.
GONZALND AN ASSODE
OFHEHOOL OHOOL ANDDR. INANK YOUH
THSTARNED TODAY. TN THE UNITED
IS COMINGO , DPLOR
TWO STATESERAV
ADAMANT AGAIMAWHAT DU F
TATEDE
I LIVEE,AND WITHKS
A REPUBLICANOVAT'SATD RATES IN S
CIERY
FOR QUITAWHILE.ER
, WHICE GOVERNORF D LITICIPANDEW
PANDEMIC, THE GOOR TO ALLOWOCHOA
OR ANY
MAINIONS FOR THEIRCUSTOMERS.
I  WE
GOORF FLORIDKS I
DOINTH
PANDEMI                       P
OF PUBC  D GONZALEZ, YOU HAD
SIMO D  A
MAEM15OUY  VACCINATED.CAE UNVAC.
HOW DITH HAPPE
I MEAN, DIE
>> WELL, WHETH FIRST STARTED
ATE ON WE SAW THIS
SPIKE IN COVID CASES
VACCINATED EMPLOYEES BUTEE
MIND, WE,0MP
AND 90%  VACCINATED SOE  VERY F
EES AND E' S
THAT THE RATES OF INFECTIOG THE
HAVE VACCINATIONS IN PLACE, WE
UCSE WHOD T'S EAINT.TH NEWS IS
POSITIVED .S TELL YS REALLY THE
TH VS
THE DATAD Y WE
TH
AT PS IS REALL
E GOIN AS , GOINSEE MORE BREAKAT
THESE BREAKTHROUGH IN MARE LIKE.
VA TURT TO B
ADVERTISED.
EF
PRHOSPITALIZATN.THAT'S THE MGE
UNVATINUE
VERY WL.>> I, WHAN
WE BECAUSE SO MANY
PEOPLE ARECINATED,R.
NZALEZ, SWIEVEN B AA
COUNTIES REINSTATED
NECESSARY THYOU'RE
SEEING?
O,AT WE'RE SEEIN
TH LEVELS UR
COMMUNITY AND BECAUSE  DELTA
STRAIN IS SO INFECTIOUS,NOT HAVE
PREVENT
PROJECTIONOU70% MIGHT
T US THIDESTRAIN, IT'S LIK80 OR.
I DATE IS
WED IFR MEDICAAVL MASKING,
EVEN THOUGH  THIS NUMBER
AMONGLOWESEEN